First of all, do I look so broke?
Have I poorly present to myself on the internet for that long
that I'm making people think I'm getting government benefits
like that? Wow.
Okay, I guess I'm the problem.
But Miss Novi Naomi,
however you wanna pronounce your name with your private account.
Okay.
Doesn't identify as Dutch,
but has outkidding and TouTiao,
I'm sure. First of all,
ain't no outkidding over here,
because I can say with confidence,
I make more than you do. I don't know who you are,
what you do, what you look like,
but based on that attitude,
I can say confidently, I make more than you.
So much that I'm not fit to get an educating.
No offense to the people who get an educating
because of health benefits,
other financial situations. Understandable,
but I work for my money. I went to school.
You girls got a bachelor and a master's degree before the age of 22.
So thank you very much. Shut up!
First of all, my page.
Nobody asked you to come here with your crappy attitude.
Y'all trying to make me spiral.
I don't wanna die. I ain't trying to come at people that hard,
but this is so out of line.
Out of line? No Zoro to slug. No!
I pay for all this with my hard earned money, okay?
Leave me alone. The only girl
what I have created from this overhyde
where I don't have to study that. Okay? Try me again